you know Tesla gets a lot of regulatory
oversight on the automotive front I
we're subject to I think over a 100
Regulatory Agencies domestically and
internationally it's a lot you could
fill this room with the all the
regulations that Tesla has to adhere to
for
automotive um same is true in you know
for rockets and for you
know um currently the limiting factor
for SpaceX for Starship launch is atory
approval the fa has actually given their
approval but we're waiting for fish and
wildlife to uh finish their analysis and
give their approval that that's why I
posted I want to buy a fish license
on which also refers the montypython
sketch
yeah like why do you need a license for
your fish I I don't
know according to the rules I'm told you
need some sort of fish license or
something we effectively need a fish
license to to rocket
and I'm like wait a second how did the
fish come into this picture yeah um I
mean so some of the things like that
it's I feel like are so absurd that I
want to do like comedy sketch and Flash
at the bottom this is all real this is
actually what happened um you know one
of the things that was a bit of a
challenge at one point is that they were
worried about uh a rocket hitting a
shock mhm and um now the ocean's very
big and how often do you see shocks uh
not that often you know as a percentage
of ocean surface area shocks basically
are zero and and and so then we will
then we said well how will we calculate
the probability of telling a shock and
they're like well we can't give you that
information because they're worried
about shark hunt shark fin Hunters uh
going and hunting sharks I say well how
are we supposed to we're on the horns of
a dilemma then
um then they said well there's another
part of fish life that can can do this
analysis and like well why don't you
give them the data like we don't they
don't we don't trust them like excuse me
you don't they're literally in your
department again this is actually what
happened um and uh and and and can you
do an NDA or
something eventually they managed to
solve the internal quander and indeed uh
the probability of ofing a shock is
essentially zero um then there's another
organization that I didn't realize
existed until uh you know a few months
ago uh that cares about whether you we
would potentially hit a whale in
international waters now again you look
at the surface of the look at the look
at the Pacific and say what percentage
of this the Pacific consists of whale
like it give you a big picture and like
point out all the whales in this picture
I'm like I don't see any whales it's
like basically 0% um and if our rocket
does hit a whale which is extremely
unlikely beyond all belief um that is
the the Fate had it in that's a well has
some seriously bad luck MH you know
that's like least lucky well ever um and
um I mean this is quite
absurd bureaucracy the bureaucracy of
this however it emerged yes well I mean
one one of the things that's pretty wild
is um for launching out of vanburg in
California we had to they were worried
about uh seal procreation whether the
seals would be dismayed by the Sonic
booms um now there have been a lot of
rockets launched out of vur and the seal
population has uh steadily increased um
so if anything rocket booms are an eort
easc um based on the evidence if you
correlate rocket launchers with uh
sealed population um nonetheless we were
forced to kidnap a seal strap it to a
board put headphones on the seal and
play Sonic Boom sounds to it to see if
it would be
distressed this is an actual thing that
happened this is actually real I have
pictures I would love to see this yeah
there I mean sorry there's a seal with
headphones yes it's a seal with
headphones yeah strapped to a board and
and like the okay now the amazing part
is how calm the seal was yeah because if
I was a seal i' be like this is the
end they're definitely going to eat me
yeah um how old the seal when seal goes
back to other you know seal friends
how's he going to explain that they're
never going to believe him never going
to believe him that's why I'm like well
you know sort of like it's like getting
kidnapped by aliens and getting an anal
probe you
know you come back and I swear to God I
got kidnapped by aliens and they stuck
anal Pro in my butt and people like no
they didn't that's ridiculous Seal Seal
buddies are never going to believe him
that he gets dra a Ward and they put
headphones on his
ears and then let him go
twice by the way we had to do it
twice they let him go twice we had to
Capt the same seal well no different
seal oh
okay did you uh did you get a seal of
approval yeah exactly a seal of approval
no I mean this is this is like I don't
think the public is quite aware of the
the madness that goes
on yeah it's yeah it's absurd freaking
seals with freaking headphones I mean
this is the it's a good encapsulation of
of the absurdity of human civiliz seals
and headphones
yes